For more than a decade, Dennis Franz was one
of the most recognizable faces on television
thanks to his role as Andy Sipowicz on NYPD
Blue.
But since the series wrapped in 2005, he hasn't
appeared in a single movie or TV show.
Why?
Here's the real reason you don't hear from
Dennis Franz anymore.
From 1993 to 2005, Dennis Franz anchored NYPD
Blue, portraying Andy Sipowicz for a good
chunk of the character's life, as well as
his own.
Twelve years is a long time to hold a job,
and by the end of it, Franz had had enough.
Instead of moving on to another project, he
decided to just retire.
He told The New York Post,
"I was just tired.
It was becoming a job, as much as I loved
the work and the challenges and the creative
process...I just wanted to live an enjoyable,
irresponsible, spend-time-with-my-family kind
of life.
I haven't regretted one minute of it.
I'm pretty good at doing nothing."
Franz and his wife now spend a lot of time
at their lake house in northern Idaho when
they aren't traveling around the world.
Sounds a lot better than tracking down killers
every week!
Andy Sipowicz might be one of the most famous
TV cops of all time, but the character was
far from the first law enforcement officer
Franz had played in his long career.
In fact, Franz told the Los Angeles Times
that by his own count, Sipowicz was the 28th
police officer he had portrayed
across television, movies, and theater.
He was so typecast that he almost didn't take
the NYPD Blue gig at all.
"I told myself I was going to try to find
another vehicle.
It was time not to play any more cop roles."
It's no wonder he decided to retire!
"How's it feel?"
"Takes some getting used to."
Before teaming up with legendary TV writer-producer
Steven Bochco on Hill Street Blues and NYPD
Blue, among others, Franz made his name in
film as a regular for two of the most most
important and singular directors of the 1970s
and 1980s: Brian De Palma and Robert Altman.
Franz appeared in five De Palma movies during
the director's peak: The Fury, Dressed to
Kill, Blow Out, Scarface, and Body Double.
He also joined Altman's ensemble films A Wedding,
Popeye, and The Player.
Sadly, though, Altman passed away in 2006,
while Bochco passed in 2018.
And while De Palma is still active, his output
has slowed dramatically.
It's understandable if Franz would rather
stay retired rather than go it alone without
any of his biggest creative partners.
Though he hasn't appeared on screen in years,
Franz has had his fair share of real life
drama.
For instance, in 2007, a huge chandelier fell
from the ceiling in Franz's house in Idaho,
injuring his sister Marlene.
The two sued for negligence, with Franz revealling
that as a result of the accident, he was forced
to forgo a $16 million personal services contract,
which suggests fans might have missed out
on a possible comeback project thanks to the
faulty chandelier.
And in 2010, Franz was involved in another
lawsuit, calming he was owed nearly $70,000
by a charter jet company for services he paid
for but never received.
Luckily, they were able to come to an agreement
before the matter went to trial.
Dennis Franz hasn't acted on screen since
2005, so fans were pleasantly surprised when
he made an unexpected appearance at the 2016
Emmys.
It sparked rumors of a possible comeback,
something that Franz told the New York Post
is still a possibility.
"My agents have an understanding; they're
still gonna knock on my door periodically
to see if there are any home runs to get me
off my butt, but so far that hasn't presented
itself, though I left my options open and
didn't say I was, for sure, closing the door
and not leaving it open a crack."
Here's hoping someone offers him a juicy role
sometime soon.
Just… no more cops, okay?